il y a un problème majeur qui est le
grand remplacement du peuple français
par un autre peuple par les noms de
civilisation
pas de fatalité ni aux grandes et
classement ni au grand remplacement
il ya 20 ans le concept de remplacement
au été catalogué xénophobes par tout le
monde
aujourd'hui le fait est qu'il ne l'est
pas
non plus en plus on voit parler du grand
remplacement
61% des français croit en la possibilité
du gouffre le remplacement c'est une
idée qu en fait une représentation
raciale et raciste du monde qui ne
repose pas sur des faits scientifiques
objectifs mais qu'on va retrouver
partout repris par des hommes politiques
repris dans les médias
remplacements
être remplacé ça fait peur se veut dire
que vous disparaissez
ça peut éveiller des délires de passer à
la violence chez des amis lui qui
naturellement ils sont prédisposés à de
france info ce matin vous emmène au sein
de l'ultra-droite des groupuscules
soupçonnait de vouloir organiser des
actions terroristes
on voyait vraiment l'efficacité de la
petite phrase quoi la petite race que
tout le monde reprend le karcher de
sarkozy alors en remplacement de renaud
camus et sa frappe et des imaginaires
ça vous fait plaisir quand les
politiques reprennent cette forme et
tout ce qui va dans le sens de la prise
de conscience de la réalité du grand
remplacement me fait plaisir sur moi je
suis effrayé par la lenteur du processus
la peur d'une invasion d'immigrés sur
notre sol est elle une obsession
nationale
paradoxalement ce fantasme qui ne repose
sur aucune donnée statistique émergent à
l'époque où la france incarne
l'envahisseur elle bâtit un empire dans
d'immenses territoires d'afrique et
d'asie
l'idée du grand emplacement c'est pas
une idée neuve
or on pourrait presque la faire remonter
au 19e siècle au moment où l'occident à
la maîtrise du monde
pour faire simple 80% des terres
émergées et connus sont occupés par des
grands empires
et à ce moment là il ya cette idée qu'il
y a des races différentes sur terre et
keren hiérarchie entre ces races et que
justement le mélange des races serait
quelque chose de dangereux
il ya déjà cette peur au 19e qui s'est
inscrite du danger du métissage du
danger en fin de compte de perdre son
âme et son identité
à cette époque les exotiques comme on
appelle les natifs des colonies sont
invisibles en métropole
les français les découvre lors
d'expositions coloniale où ils sont
présentés en bête mystérieuse
l'indigène est plus un fantasme qu'une
réalité le grand méchant loup qui menace
de dévorer la france
anduze 194 un livre va faire un tabac un
succès incroyable plusieurs millions
d'exemplaires le certainement un des
grands best-sellers de la fin 19e telle
invasion noir du capitaine d'enrique
l'invasion noire signée d'un officier
français une formule bien proche de
celle du grand remplacement
l'histoire d'une armée d'africains
manoeuvré par des musulmans qui envahit
l'europe
je pense que la meilleure manière de
caractériser libre est d'arriver à
comprendre les affiches qui avait dans
tout paris on voit en fin de compte un
homme arabe très barbu le doigt fixé
vers la mecque qui brille itella soleil
à ses pieds une centaine de combattants
noir ils viennent de décapiter des
officiers français et qui à travers
cette symbolique la vise l'islam va
guider les masses noires qui vont venir
envahir l'occident et nous détruire
à la veille de la guerre 14 18 il ya
toute une idée qu'il y a donc l'épongé à
nos portes qu'il faut se protéger et que
nous n'avons pas assez de gens
[Musique]
dix ans après la publication du livre la
france mobilise les hommes de ses
colonies
un million d'hommes de couleurs viennent
en occident pendant la première guerre
mondiale on voit l'autre
ils sont présents à l'arrière dans les
hôpitaux ils ne vivent plus à distance
vers proximité ils ne sont plus dans les
empires mais en même temps la métropole
et d'un seul coup ça fait un débat à
l'intérieur de la société française ce
danger qui était alors à dire lointain
et toucher une minorité de gens devient
un danger maintenant en occident même au
regard de la première guerre mondiale
avec une population africaine qui
s'installe en métropole naissent déjà
des théories complotistes
[Musique]
l'idée de la dangerosité d'un potentiel
remplacement elle s'associe toujours un
qui les accompagnent on considère donc
qu'il y aurait des traîtres à
l'intérieur des sociétés occidentales ça
peut être sur la gauche qui va chercher
le vote immigrés ça peut être les francs
maçons qui vont chercher des alliés aux
colonies ça peut être les femmes qui
serait fasciné par le ccor exotiques de
l'autre ça pour être les juifs
qui par définition trouve des alliés
pour quelques pains soir leur place dans
la société occidentale
pendant les années de nazisme les juifs
concentre la haine de l'extrême droite
européenne
après la déroute allemande d'anciens
collaborateurs ou combattants de la
waffen ss font évoluer leur doctrine
l'antisémitisme reste au coeur de leur
idéologie mais il y accole des vieilles
références coloniale l'idée selon
laquelle les blancs seraient menacées
d'extinction
après la seconde guerre mondiale
certains groupes radicaux disent
il ya un pouvoir secret juifs qui
essaient de détruire la race blanche en
fait la seconde guerre mondiale c'est la
faute des juifs qui manoeuvrait l'union
soviétique et les états unis s'est
excusé la propagande nazie et ils
veulent finir maintenant l'europe en y
important des africains et des
asiatiques pour finir de la détruire et
instaurer leur dictature juive mondiale
donc tous ces thèmes là on les voit qui
commencent à apparaître autour de cette
idée qui a une colonisation de l'europe
et qu'il faut libérer l'europe
ce complot juif visant à remplacer la
population blanche servirait ce que
l'univers d'extrême droite nomme
désormais le mondialisme
une théorie complotiste de plus qui
traverse l'atlantique la version
américaine du grand remplacement se
traduit en white chesneau side le
génocide des blancs la peur que les
descendants d'esclaves surpasse en
nombre la population majoritaire
[Musique]
le white génocide c'est un thème central
du néonazisme américain et dans cette
idée que toute la politique
l'affluence d'hollywood les relations
internationales visent le génocide des
blancs il s'agit de faire disparaître la
race blanche c'est le thème du grand
remplacement dans le vocabulaire du
néonazisme américain
en france on va avoir des idées tout à
fait proches on va également expliquer
que les mêmes fléau le cinéma pour
mission la pornographie la légalisation
de l'avortement de la pilule visent tous
à détruire les européens blancs
ces idées se diffuse dans les différents
courants de l'extrême droite
l'obsession antisémite s'est déplacée
vers une haine des immigrés arabes
africains ou asiatiques
80 ans après l'invasion noir un nouveau
livre réveille les vieux démons en 1973
jean raspail publie son plus grand
succès le camp des saints un roman
décrivant des bateaux remplis de
migrants indien qui débarque sur nos
côtes
imaginez qu'un jour un million de gens
misérables en barque venant du gange sur
les vieux bateau fasse le tour de
l'afrique et débarque en france
pacifiquement à un million et puis
d'autres flotte derrière qui sont prêtes
à partir la question que pose ce lycée
qu'est ce qu'on fait ce qu'on les laisse
entrer ou non là
en réalité dans cet ouvrage rien de
pacifique les migrants sont des barbares
qui détruisent tout sur leur passage
c'est très violent le
les indiens qui arrive violent qui tue
même les ong qui viennent les aider il
faut c'est absolument effarant
[Musique]
dans le livre il parle de grandes
migrations s'est pas d'agrandissement ya
déjà le mot grand
qui est affirmé c'est la fin de la
civilisation française
douze ans plus tard le romancier se
muant journalistes il affirme chiffres à
l'appui que la réalité va dépasser la
fiction
c'est aussi lui qui a monté quelques
années plus tard après son roman un
dossier qui est restée célèbre du figaro
magazine dont le titre était serons-nous
français dans 30 ans
et il y avait une très belle couverture
du montrait une marianne vous allez
c'était un travail avec des hypothèses
qu'on peut maintenant qualifié de
fantaisiste
[Musique]
1985 et 30 ans après c'est 2015 j'ai les
chiffres pour 2015 bien sûr et on voit
qu'elle et l'amplitude des erreurs
commises par cette projection
même si ces chiffres se révèle
complètement faux le romancier devient
un phare de l'extrême droite
le magazine valeurs actuelles trente ans
après la une du figaro le qualifie même
de prophètes
la peur d'une france menacée par des
hordes d'immigrés fait son chemin
[Musique]
donc vous voyez comment des petits
fleuves finalement en format grand et
bien des termes qui sont un peu éparses
des idées qui sont encore un peu vague
qu'elle finisse par se rassembler et
puis on arrive à 7 ce grand remplacement
comment c'est tombé sur renaud camus
sereine je ne sais pas mais enfin c'est
lui qui de la formule et
en 2010
renaud camus invente la formule du grand
remplacement
deux simples mots qui synthétise
l'imaginaire colonial le génocide blanc
l'invasion des immigrés
pour le rencontrer il faut se perdre sur
les routes du gers dans le sud-ouest de
la france un petit village surplombé
d'un château du 14e siècle
le maître des lieux il ya installé son
atelier de peinture
à côté de la pièce principale où il
écrit ses livres
[Musique]
renaud camus 75 ans condamné pour
provocation à la haine est un homme
prudent qui demande à son assistant de
filmer notre rencontre
[Musique]
pourquoi vous filmez vous aussi cet
entretien
a parce que nous sommes habitués aux
plus mauvaises expériences à ce genre là
des montages incroyable des phrases
isolé sortis de leur contexte donc très
malheureusement
devoir tout certes belle-fille hausse
mais malgré cela vous continuez de
de recevoir des journalistes chez vous
renaud camus aime se raconter il décrit
sa révélation lorsqu'il aperçoit des
femmes voilées dans un village médiéval
le symbole à ses yeux de la disparition
de la population française au profit
d'une immigration non européenne
l'origine de la formule qu'il a inventé
le grand remplacement
je suppose qu'elle m'est venue par
assimilation avec d'autres formules
semblable pour désigner les époques
la grande peste la grande guerre la
grande dépression
d'autres termes
qui décrivent aussi violent la situation
je j'assume totalement le terme de
colonisation les mêmes de dire que
l'europe est aujourd'hui beaucoup plus
colonisé qu'elle n'a jamais le colonisé
elle même
selon renaud camus ce remplacement de
population serait synonyme de
déclassement de violence et de décadence
son livre le grand remplacement qu'il
dédie à jean raspail et truffé
d'expressions guerrière
la conquête et la conversion islamique
l'étouffement programmes et de grandes
cultures
les cohortes serré du grand remplacement
[Applaudissements]
des soldats le bras armé de la conquête
sur twitter il va plus loin encore il
évoque un génocide par substitution des
européens annoncer aux africains qu'on
tirera sur s'ils continuent leur
invasion
passe mon temps devant les tribunaux je
suis d'ailleurs en général
le condamné
parce qu'il ne faut pas dire ceci parce
qu'il veut pas dire cela c'est à dire
parce qu'il ne faut pas donner
l'évidence oui évidemment ce sont
très grandes sinon en majeure partie des
transformations de nature ethnique place
non
cette vision du remplacement d'une
population par une autre est contredite
par les études scientifiques
mais pour lui la science n'est qu'un
détail
[Musique]
c'est comme une fille jeanne d'arc se
présenter charles c'est en utilisant en
face here le pays est occupée par les
anglais il faut faire quelque chose ce
que charles vii ont eu l'idée de lui
répondre enfin vous avez les chiffres
exacts mais ce que jean moulin
besoins de la science de la sociologie
pour savoir que la france ait des spas
pays occupés la
recherche de la petite phrase toujours
quitte à comparer des immigrés à une
armée d'occupation
renaud camus affirme dans ses livres que
la simple observation suffit pour
constater le remplacement de la
population française
un postulat absurde pour un démographe
comme hervé le bras qui s'appuie depuis
des décennies sur les recensements
chiffres et des français
renaud camus répète ce leitmotiv des
ignorants comme quoi la statistique
c'est du mensonge
c'est pas dans son château de plieux qui
peut comprendre comment sont les 67
millions de français a aucune chance
pour comprendre qui sont les 67 millions
de français il faut des statistiques
quand on regarde la dernière année il ya
eu 109 mille immigrés de plus sans 9000
sur une population de 60 7 millions
d'habitants
comment voulez-vous que 109 mille
personnes arrivant chaque année remplace
la population française c'est absolument
impossible
et puis pour pierre grand remplacement
il faudrait qu'ils aient vraiment d'un
côté une population homogène celle qui
va être remplacé et puis de l'autre
notre population homogène qui remplace
or dans les deux cas on n'a pas assez de
population homogène il ya une très
grande mixité la moitié pratiquement des
descendants d'immigrés sont des
descendantes d'unions mixtes donc en
train rapidement quand on arrive à la
deuxième ou troisième génération
l'ascendant c'est extraordinairement
variées
mais là encore les faits les chiffres
l'épreuve ne pèse pas lourd face à
l'efficacité de la formule
renaud camus dont la plupart des livres
était passée inaperçue devient une
référence son expression le grand
remplacement fait mouche
oui
certaines figures de l'extrême droite y
ont trouvé un intérêt en vue enfin une
slogan quelque chose qui pouvait voilà
assénées en public et je suis
suffisamment mobilisateur
comme le mouvement génération
identitaire connu pour des actions coup
de poing contre les migrants ou la
viande halal
dissout par l'état en 2021 qui
s'approprie l'expression
les identitaires par exemple parlait
avant que le remplacement n'existe en
tant que formule dans le champ politique
de l'invasion de l'islamisation
canton des grands emplacements ont dit
tout ça à la fois on est à la fois qu'on
est que la france est envahie à la fois
que l'identité de la france va changer
on dit à la fois qu'on est islamisée
donc en fait c'est un outil politique
très utile pour donc formé
[Musique]
en fait ils proposent un plan une
réponse au grand remplacement et cette
réponse c'est la rémunération
donc on va interdire le port du voile
dans l'espace public interdire la vente
de nourriture halal ou communautaires
plus d'être social pour les immigrés fin
de la double nationalité
et puis troisième étape organiser le
retour des émigrés chez eux
le grand remplacement pourrait être un
constat la rémunération est le programme
qui va avec ce constat
un grand événement qui s'appelle les
assises de la rémunération viendra e
renaud camus d'ailleurs il prenait la
parole à la tribune l'événement il est
sous titré du grand remplacement au
grand retour
le grand remplacement et la crise la
plus grave qu'ait connue la france
depuis quinze siècles
sylar obligation qui est la seule
réplique possible la pas lieu
l'histoire continuera peut-être mais ce
ne sera plus la même
les amis de renaud camus vont tout faire
pour promouvoir la formule qui l'a
inventé leur arme la plus efficace les
réseaux sociaux
l'objectif est de sortir des petits
cercles radicaux et d'atteindre le grand
public
23 mai 2013 eh bien on se rend compte
que il y à une opération organisée par
des militants d'extrême droite
qui décide pour la première fois de
l'histoire de twitter où pour la
première fois sur ce média la de mener
une forme d' opération de communication
visant à faire monter le hashtag le mot
diez prend en placements dans les ce
qu'on appelle les trending topics c'est
à dire dans les tendances à l'oeuvre sur
twitter et donc ils se donnent rendez
vous entre 17 heures à 19 heures et ils
doivent tous street et à ce moment là
avec le hashtag grands emplacements
rendez vous important à tous les
patriotes c'est sur twitter on utilise
le hashtag remplacement vers 17 18
heures venez nombreux et ça fonctionne
auparavant on était à un rythme de
quelques tweets par jour et à partir de
ce jour là et jusqu'à aujourd'hui la
tendance ne va jamais baissé et on va
passer plutôt à plusieurs dizaines voire
centaines de troupes par jour
au fil du temps l'idée de grand
remplacement se banalise elle est
reprise par des influenceurs d'extrême
droite très populaire et devient une
formule choc à la mode
c'était se sont beaucoup répandues par
le truchement effectivement d'internet
des espaces de discussions de forums et
sakho ne voit là un certain succès
à force d'être marteau laisse voilà ça a
commencé à frapper un peu l'opinion
aujourd'hui l'extrême droite est
majoritaire sur internet celles qui ne
fonctionnent le mieux c'est elle qui a
une capacité à faire du buzz c'est avec
une capacité à imposer ses thématiques
dans l'espace des réseaux sociaux
la conséquence c'est que leurs idées ont
un bib et toute une génération de jeunes
gens placent aussi regarder sur
wikipédia c'est une théorie d'extrême
droite conspiration titre la culture
française elle est en voie de
disparition ça ne cohabitent pas ça
remplace la bagarre
qui fait que ça marche sur ce public là
c'est que ces sont des thèses les thèses
racistes et xénophobes les thèses
antisémites va paraissent très
sulfureuse en paraissent très radicale
et sur le net qui fonctionne c'est ça
salut la commune aujourd'hui on va
tester si le gauchisme et par balles
les petites stars d'extrême droite sur
internet utilisent les mêmes codes que
les humoristes et imposent leur discours
[Musique]
ne soyez plus des mauviettes soyez des
hommes forts à moquez-vous des bobos des
gros tas de merde décérébrés font du
vélo d'appartement tout en sons qui
feront de malbouffe toxiques chez
mcdonald's faut s'habiller de manière
virile il faut surtout pas manger du
soja il faut manger de la bonne viande
trois doigts comme ça le pousse ici mais
j'ai vraiment faim quand les français
mais dans une bouffe ça
des sachets de graines mais en tout cas
ce qui fait le trait d'union entre
toutes les figures influentes
aujourd'hui l'extrême droite disons 2.0
c'est bien le concept de remplacement
c'est meilleur des mondes ses comptes
doivent le quitter mais
c'est l'idée que la france est en péril
parce qu'elle est en train d'être
submergée par l'immigration noirs et
arabes
les identitaires et leurs relais
prennent de plus en plus de place
certains sont invités à la télévision
aux heures de grande écoute sur le
plateau de cyril hanouna le youtuber
baptiste marchait ou la porte parole de
générations identitaire thaïs des ce
qu'ils font ils arrivent malgré leur
petit nombre a
à faire lance fusées leurs idées alors
souvent ça passe en fait par des
intermédiaires ils le font pas tout seul
c'est parce qu'ils trouvent des caisses
de résonance
et puis un homme va imposer leur vision
dans le débat public
vouloir la premier création ce n'est pas
être raciste c'est considérer qu'il ya
trop d'immigrés en france que ça pose un
vrai problème
équilibre démographique et identitaire
et xénon là et est une caisse de
résonance pour eux et pour leurs idées
les militants le soutiennent et eric
zemmour
incarne un peu ce courant identitaire en
fait dans le débat public
en septembre 2019 l'éditorialiste
d'extrême droite bascule vers la
politique
invité par marion maréchal-le pen à la
convention de la droite il récite dans
un discours retransmis en direct à la
télévision l'idée du grand remplacement
de renaud camus
les jeunes français vont ils accepter de
vivre en minorité sur la terre de leurs
ancêtres
la grande nation crainte dans toute
l'europe et le monde entier est devenu
un retournement incroyable larmes de
destruction de la nation et de
l'asservissement de son peuple du
remplacement de son pop à un autre
peuple une autre civilisation
trois ans plus tard eric zemmour est
candidat à l'élection présidentielle il
rend le concept plus présentable
[Musique]
l'idée de grand remplacement nettoyer de
son aspect conspirationnistes et
antisémites devient la base de son
programme politique
cette idée un remplacement n'avait pas
été posée comme ça avant monsieur
zemmour dans l'espace public le sujet
c'est effectivement ce fameux grand
remplacement c'est donc une question qui
est posée dans le débat public autour de
laquelle chacun est obligé de se situer
est ce que c'est une réponse à ce que
j'ai réalisé mon rappel le grand
remplacement les deux craintes des
français grand déclassement grand
remplacement comme eric zemmour a pu le
dire comme jordan parallèle a dit
récemment qu'un grand remplacement est à
l'oeuvre vous je vous ai enfin de nous
dire que oui il y a une forme de grand
emplacement dans certains cas
[Musique]
les médias prennent le relais le grand
remplacement devient un sujet des
missions d'articles
ces débats clivants vous permettre de
produire un spectacle médiatique
intéressant
on peut rapidement comprendre que le
public sera plus intéressés par un débat
sur le sur la théorie du grand
emplacement que sur les orientations
économiques du gouvernement au cours de
ces dernières années
et les instituts de sondage joue le même
jeu en octobre 2021 le magazine
challenges publie cette étude signée
harris interactive certaines personnes
parlent du grand remplacement les
populations européennes blanche et
chrétienne étant menacées d'extinction
suite à l'immigration musulmane
provenant du maghreb et de l'afrique
noire pensez vous qu'un tel phénomène va
se produire une formulation qui
contribue à banaliser le concept en
quelques phrases une idée basée sur des
mensonges statistiques devient légitime
le choix qui a été fait c'est de ne pas
indiquer l'origine politique de la
théorie du remplacement ni ses auteurs
on sait que c'est une théorie qui a été
formulée par des auteurs des penseurs
d'extrême droite très concrètement si
c'était indiqué dans la question il ya
de fortes chances pour que la
distribution des réponses ne sera pas de
soi pas la même ce qui est curieux
également c'est la suite de la question
alors c'est des populations européennes
blanche et chrétienne étant menacées
d'extinction suite à l'immigration
musulmane étant menacées d'extinction
c'est comme si ce phénomène du grand
emplacement était avérée donc il ya
d'autant plus de raisons de s'en
inquiéter
résultats affichés 61% des français
pensent qu'un grand remplacement est
possible
67 % s'en inquiète ces chiffres obtenus
avec une méthode contestable sont repris
dans toute la presse s'est parfaitement
conforme à l'économie médiatique actuel
qui repose sur sur une logique du buzz
sur une logique du clash ça produit des
effets d'accréditation c'est à dire ça
rend le phénomène d'autant plus réel
alors qui sait leur pause empiriquement
sur des bases fragiles
et c'est par cette mécanique l'alliance
des réseaux sociaux et des médias que
l'idée d'un grand remplacement va
voyager
le 9 mars 2010 cette suite à un tweet de
robert ménard lumière de béziers qui
parle du fait que le grand emplacement
est bien visible
le média russe rt le traduit en anglais
et donc donne de la visibilité à cette
déclaration robert ménard dans une
sphère anglo saxon et l' extrême droite
américaine reprend le sujet il ya
quelques articles qui parlent de ce
replacement
un tweet de robert ménard affiliés au
rassemblement national traduit par rt
médias russes proche de l'extrême droite
aboutisse à faire connaître la notion de
grenoble et nantes en amérique
on retrouve sa trace quelques mois plus
tard à peine dans une petite ville de
virginie aux états unis charlottesville
charleville on est au sud des états unis
et va y avoir une manifestation avec des
gens de tous les groupes radicaux de
droite américain qui convergent pour
protéger la statue du général lee chef
militaire des confédérés
[Musique]
et on va avoir deux types de groupes
avec un slogan un peu différent qui vont
marquer les esprits
d'un côté il ya des gens des milieux
qu'on appelle la ride c'est en gros en
france des identitaires et outils ce
slogan vous ne nous rappelant serez pas
en parlant des noirs des latinos etc
de l'autre côté guy à l'extrême droite
radicale américaine classique les gens
qui viennent des milieux suprémacistes
d'une au nazisme américains qui eux
crient juifs vous ne nous remplacerait
pas
on a là en même temps deux visions du
grand remplacement une vision qu'on a en
france qui est juste la dénonciation des
migrants
et notre version qui correspond à la
culture démarche radicale qui et c'est
le complot juif mondial qui organise
autres remplacements raciale
le lendemain une contre manifestation
est organisée
un jeune néo nazis font sans voiture sur
la foule
[Musique]
racault
[Applaudissements]
11 heures
un mort 35 blessés
l'idée d'un grand remplacement tu ce
n'est ni la première fois ni la dernière
cela fait des années qu une vague
d'attentats d'extrême droite s'est
fracassé sur le monde occidental
[Musique]
le premier terroristes inspirés par
cette idéologie frappe la norvège en
2011 il s'appelle anders breivik
je vois un train d'effectuer un saut de
l'avant
trawick la
mauritanie score
center
procès en europe
[Musique]
oui choque et vingt six minutes
on a tous la
bulle explose
ironise way to the next target aux
libertés ou face à wasquehal
ouais les filles d'acquérir le polynôme
story et aspen à la
barre
fixe
[Musique]
après avoir tué sept personnes à oslo
anders breivik 32 ans
vise l'île d'utoya à une heure de route
de la capitale six cents jeunes
militants qui sont réunis
m
[Musique]
vous
le chante
peter fini par se jeter à l'eau où il
est secouru par un bateau
breivik est arrêté par la police sans
aucune résistance après avoir tué 69
personnes
le plus jeune avait 14 ans
avant de passer à l'acte anders breivik
a rédigé un texte de 1500 pages intitulé
date à laquelle selon lui les musulmans
seraient majoritaires en europe
il déroule son obsession de l'invasion
de l'islam et de la disparition des
valeurs européennes
[Musique]
avec i want someone else to leave your
bike and run
[Musique]
des wings mike babcock
a mal gamehope
ssp
world of lords of copycat
is making and you how to become
terrorisme afvt à double cible mec a
movement votre fille à smart
la vague de violence rêvé par anders
breivik ne vient pas
il faut une conjonction d'événements
internationaux pour que l'ultra droite
se réveille
incontestablement l'année 2015 et
charnière
c'est l'époque où se produit la vague
migratoire en provenance de la zone syro
irakienne
et en france j'avais les attentats de
novembre
et si l'attentât de novembre
ils sont massifs
et sont coordonnés
et ils éteignent toutes les strates
sociologique de la population
et là vous avez une image qui en 2004 je
pense à totalement remis en forme cette
idée de la vision d'un seul coup tous
ses fantasmes du siècle passé deviennent
très concret en 2015 vous n'avez même
pas besoin pour l'extrême droite c'est
du pain béni vous avez même pas besoin
d'inventer quelque chose vous avez tous
les ingrédients de la démonstration et
du dangereux et dont il parle depuis des
générations
brevik tout le monde est horrifiée mais
il ne fait pas d'émules pourquoi parce
qu'il manque justement contexte 2015
candace breivik frappe ya pas eu la
crise des réfugiés il n'y a pas eu les
attentats en france résultat ils
trouvent pas d'imitateur de suite par
contre aujourd'hui il est considéré
comme un saint comme un martyr comme un
héros comme justement celui qui a ouvert
la voie et s'est pas complètement fou
quelque part il ouvre la voie
dans les cinq années qui suivent les
violences de l'ultra droite augmente
dans le monde de 320%
le 27 octobre 2018 robert powers
mitraillent la foule dans une synagogue
de pittsburgh aux états unis onze morts
ses derniers mots avant de passer à
l'action je ne peux pas rester sans rien
faire et regarder mon peuple se faire
tuer le 3 août 2019 à el paso toujours
aux états unis patrick russe us dénonce
une invasion hispanique du texas et
parle de grand remplacement ils
assassinent 22 personnes
le 9 octobre 2019 à halle en allemagne
stéphane baly tu tires sur une synagogue
puis un restaurant turc dans une vidéo
ils dénoncent les juifs source de tous
les problèmes les féministes cause du
déclin des naissances et l'immigration
de masse
le 10 août 2019 à oslo en norvège un
admirateur d'anders breivik tirs sur les
fidèles d'une mosquée il dit vouloir
provoquer une guerre des races
le 15 mars 2019 à christ cherche en
nouvelle zélande brenton torrent
attaques de deux mosquées ils tuent
cinquante et une personnes film et
diffuse l'attentât en direct sur
facebook il se réclame d'anvers brevik
[Musique]
juste avant l'attaqué ils diffusent lui
aussi un manifeste sur internet
intitulée en anglais le grand
remplacement
quand on regarde la couverture du
manifeste de braaten times ce qui choque
bien sûr c'est cette expression de grand
remplacement qui d'un coup d'un seul
trouve une gloire mondiale sinistre elle
n'avait pas jusque là
il ya le soleil noir symbole néonazis
important de la sub culture du
nationalisme blanc
ta rennes c'est un homme cultivé qui a
lu énormément d'auteur radicaux qui fait
sa propre synthèse et qui propose sa
propre stratégie
c'est un remplacement ethnique un
remplacement culturel un remplacement
raciale
c'est un génocide des blancs
se compose par heinze et pour la
première fois on se rend compte que ce
thème du grand remplacement en fait est
un train d'obsédé des blancs dans le
monde entier qui sont en train de
converger dans leur représentation et
pouvoir dans des moyens d'action violent
il ya une idée essentielle c'est la
question de l'accélération nisme l'idée
que l'occupation des sols européens est
telle que il faut accélérer chaos
raciale
[Musique]
l'accélération nisme une nouvelle
doctrine ultra violente voit le jour des
terroristes convaincu que le grand
remplacement est en cours et qu'il faut
prendre les armes pour l'arrêter
l'extrême droite traditionnelle est la
tendance à dire il faut faire rempart
contre la décadence et tout ce qui est
nocif pour notre peuple les
accélérations liste ils n'ont pas du
tout si vous opérez comme ça vous
sauverez des bribes mais au fond il faut
saisir toutes les occasions de mettre du
chaos dans la société de mettre de
l'opposition entre groupes religieux
communautaire différents pour que grosso
modo on en arrive à une situation de
guerre civile
aujourd'hui cette mouvance accélération
nist est l'une des principales menaces
visant la france
[Musique]
le manuel accélération liste est traduit
en français et diffusés sur les réseaux
de l'ultra droite
on y trouve un hommage aux tueurs
les cibles
et un appel à commettre des attentats
[Musique]
la france a un nombre de radicaux qui
est estimé actuellement à peu près 3000
un don milles 1300 violents et les
autres qui font caisse de résonance
il ya eu depuis 2010 est vite attentats
déjoués si ce qui est organisé par des
cellules des groupes
et deux qui étaient des démarches
individuelles terroristes
[Musique]
c'est le cas d'aurélien chapeau qui a
été condamné très récemment à nos
vallées de prison pour entreprises
terroristes individuels il avait
commencé à gagner les armes il avait
commencé à faire des recherches sur
internet pour savoir quels lieux de
culte il allait pouvoir viser et surtout
il rendait hommage à brenton tarente le
terroriste de christophe où il rendait
hommage à anders breivik le terroriste
norvégien il avait vraiment une forme de
vénération pour ces grands tueurs et
prenez comme en photo en salle fille
avec une arme de guerre un drapeau nazi
à l'arrière et le manifeste du grand
emplacement entre les mains
[Musique]
si les services de police n'était pas
intervenue il ya fort à parier que
certains seraient passés à l'acte
la menace qu'un brevik ou un tas rent
frappe la france grandi
en 2021 les services de renseignement
alerte les autorités
de nombreux attentats commis au nom de
l'ultra droite ces dernières années peut
faire craindre l'apparition d'un modus
operandi et d'une idéologie commune
portés par des acteurs isoler
les membres de cette mouvance
suprémacistes se rassemblent autour de
thématiques communes la haine et le
racisme envers les minorités la
xénophobie et l'islamophobie
l'antisémitisme ou la misogynie
ils se sont emparés de l'idéologie
popularisé par l'écrivain français
renaud camus du grand remplacement
la formule at-elle dépasser son auteur
renaud camus se défend d'un quelconque
lien avec les terroristes qui prétendent
lutter contre le grand remplacement
nous ne cessons de colle de condamner
la violence si les gens commettent des
attentats il prouve ipso facto qui ne
sont pas influencés par mois qui est
nécessaire de condamner tous les
attentats et tous les actes de violence
individuelle
votre temps
mais avant la fin de l'entretien
l'écrivain tient à préciser sa pensée
aurait dû dire quelque chose je regrette
de n'avoir pas dit je dis souvent
pourtant qui peut être nous aurait
permis de mieux comprendre je ne suis en
aucune façon pacifique je suis non
violent mais pas du tout pacifiste
je n'élimine pas du tout la guerre si
c'est pour sauver sa patrie mais je
j'écarte tout à fait
les attentats les violences les
gorges pour les massacres les accessible
choses comme ça
contre la violence mais pas contre la
guerre
c'est toute l'ambiguïté de la formule et
de son auteur
est en effet la rhétorique de
l'envahisseur derrière leur remplacement
il ya l'idée de la guerre raciale est
donc certain attrait après de ça comme
un droit de se défendre et
éventuellement bas de passer à l'acte
donc en soi le grand emplacement porte
en lui les germes d'une violence dans la
mesure où il présuppose la disparition
de la civilisation donc faut se battre
pour préserver cette civilisation quand
vous écouter les discours d'eric zemmour
sur le remplacement il vous explique qu'
on peut pas avoir deux civilisations sur
un même sol on va tirer dans les
conséquences
[Musique]
e